how's go Marella system welcome to five
that's ten damn it five weird things
stuff online
[Music]
it was really sinful of the show and I
got a lot of great suggestions by you
brush so item number one is a handy
chord really brush that's all you could
find
cuz that's [ __ ] awesome let's let's
try this baby out I can't wait
this is actually a real unicorn baby
that they chopped down in pieces and
cleaned out all right let's see if I do
this right this one goes there
[Music]
sorry that is pretty [ __ ] stupid so
now if you ever wanted to get a hand job
by a unicorn and it can happen yeah
that's that's fun for like five seconds
maybe yeah it's pretty good
[Music]
don't worry I have so many green items
today Bros you're gonna be blown away
iron number two you've suggested this
one as well notes aerobics basketball
you see that guy you see that man that's
gonna be me in a couple seconds okay so
you put them on looking pretty good and
then you try and get the basic vault and
I felt like this is appropriate dating
dating where you're going to get all the
ladies if you ride this especially if
you can nail it
you'll be like hey girl watch this wait
okay
[Music]
you're guaranteed to get late you're
welcome
[Music]
next item item number three is bacon
toothpaste makes your breath bacon fresh
so there seems to be this trend where
just you put bacon anywhere and it's
just cells oh oh well yes we gotta try
it I don't know if you can see but it
kind of has like a reddish tone to it
and I'm really bad with putting stuff in
my mouth all right oh yeah here we go
[Music]
I'm trying to not get it all my cousin's
really good you could just take a bacon
strip put some toothpaste on it and
brush your teeth
it would really might be the same thing
okay
[Music]
item number four is the fart experiment
yes someone made that make your own
noise putty fabricate appropriate potato
juice let's go baby
[Music]
hi and welcome to the fart experiment
today we're going to make fart noises
fart noises are funny
step one filled with water so now we
have the option did we want pink fart or
yellow greenish parts I prefer the
yellow greenish parts but really each to
his own own taste now just mix it in
carefully stir that [ __ ] around stir
for 10 minutes [ __ ] do you think I'm
doing with my life
[Music]
alright pressed for this week 5 weird
stuff online I have a bonus item which I
was sent which is a loot crate which is
a monthly box you can subscribe to and
it will send you different stuff every
time I'm gonna unbox this which is for
February and the theme is play I open it
and it apparently has a crate packet
similar 2015 which is a board game I
think inside that's pretty cool first
item is a money world which is a little
guy that you can paint on and design
whichever way you like I don't know
about you but I really like stuff like
this he can be creative and personal
with with weird stuff and I have like
here I have so many stuff like that
so yeah I want I won't design that now
but maybe that's something for the
future what the hell is this all right
this is a hex bug it says a micro
robotic creature that reacts to objects
all right I'm gonna have to check this
out oh my god well I can make use out of
this
oh my ass you're so [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
it's just a robot
hey I got a book in here ready player
one by Ernest cling enchanting Willy
Wonka meets The Matrix right we got a
poster a poster of pac-man which looks
pretty [ __ ] cold so these are dices
they got a breakfast on them yeah oh and
here are all the stuff and then you play
the board game on the box okay I want to
check that board game out that seems
pretty fun
this is too bad I don't have any friends
if you enjoy weird stuff like myself
then you can order your loot crate and
if you order before March 19 you will
get the coverage loot crate which is the
one coming next month so yeah the next
loot crate will be covering of covert I
don't think I say that right but it's a
it's basically espionage and spice and
all that kind of stuff it's cool how
they have a different theme for each one
check out a loot crate it's it's cool it
supports the show and if you enter pewds
you get 10% off you're welcome hello and
welcome back to my kitchen let's try out
the selfie toaster so I'm really curious
how this will actually work we got our
toaster skit some toast pop that [ __ ]
in there and it's now been 10 minutes
it's ready it says stick your fingers in
there this is [ __ ] gross but I'm
gonna stick my finger in there and it's
gonna make you guessed it fart noises
this is my life now
[Music]
toaster bread now we play the waiting
game oh geez oh god it's burning my
toast is burning it's really okay yeah I
think that's me in my stance oh it's so
[ __ ] hot let's see how delicious a
PewDiePie is as a bread need some butter
and yeah you want it oh my god ten out
of ten go ahead and leave a like if you
enjoyed this episode Rose I really
appreciate it and I love making these
type of videos for you and that's all
for now oh sorry bro there's one thing I
forgot to mention if you download the
pretty pie app you can watch the next
part of the five weird stuff with post
right now it's up on the app and order
iTunes download it and check it out also
don't forget to check out loot crate
comm slash boots support the show and
get awesome stuff bro that rhyme how
about a thang
that's all for now I think it was
watching and I'll see you in the next
one stay awesome bros great terrifying
as always
[Music]